not to be confused with Prague Oklahoma
wait there actually is a pro kleh home
well in the past 12 months you've gotten
a tattoo or undergone any ear skin or
body piercing asking important questions
like this while on the way to the
vampire place why not screen
above-ground and weed out any fake fools
before even starting down the secret
vampire path oh I'm sorry
but he didn't throw this dude anywhere
near hard enough to bust up on that wall
tile a bit of chicks neck and have
bloody teeth and am in every way
imaginable a vampire but just FYI I hate
vampires I know he's a genetically
mutated something or other but still oh
I see he's an alien from aliens with
tentacles coming out of his mouth
instead of a bitey face one also
that's not how creeper mounds work later
in the movie or even earlier now that I
think about it but since it would ruin
the dramatic reveal later in the movie
if it were done correctly here they're
probably hoping we'll forgive them but
we won't forget what you think you know
forget what you think you know cliche my
name is blade narration I was born
half-human half-vampire they called me
the day Walker previously on blade I
have all their strengths none of their
weaknesses and yet there are still a ton
of almost as though I haven't been doing
my job gave me the weapons Todd with
silver garlic sunlight he gave you
silver garlic and sunlight literally I
can doubt it but this movie is so
literally I guess I'll just go with it
though I'm wondering why and how
Whistler top blade garlic blade throws
this thing and it ultimately does
nothing and then returns to it Oh what
did someone forget to tell me that blade
has garlic infused choke rope because I
think they did also fourth-of-july
vampire us hey you offering up
information before you're asked for it
the fourth weapon against vampires that
blade forgot to mention in his earlier
narration was motorcycle tires also
holding this guy's head to the spinning
tire is terrifying but wouldn't you also
need to have a hand on the bikes
acceleration handlebar in order to make
this tire spin I feel like this scene
requires too many hands and it's there
for goofy since both the blades hands
are on this guy at some point in the
recent past these vampire hoodlums
hijacked a tasty moo-cow ice cream truck
then stacked that stolen in a
room-temperature area so as to melt it
and make it useless haha does blade miss
this guy from 10 feet away any reason
for the kick other than cinematic
looking
he's dead after the staff soaked the
kick has just wasted energy the blade
movies basically perfected the art of
the attack one at a time bad guy this
guy is trying to create the illusion
that he's actually participating in this
fight when he looks more like he's
waiting on someone to pass in the
basketball played to somehow rips off
both Alien Resurrection and die hard
with a vengeance all at once
also nice taste in movies to ripoff
movie so most useless flashlight ever
then that's cool
is the movie just gonna ignore the fact
that Abraham shot himself in a last
movie I guess so exactly how unguarded
was blades trusted mentor in this
vampire prison 100% unguarded 100% um
and they dragged pre Walking Dead Norman
Reedus into this didn't they giving him
an accelerated retroviral detox oh okay
in the morning those blinds are going to
open whether you're cured or not blade
gives his beloved mentor only a few
hours for the anti vampire detox to work
how do you feel like hammers it's not
even supposed to mean someone stumbled
upon some poop just so happen to have a
hammer and then beat the hell out of the
aren't there like a hundred better ways
to say you feel terrible long words are
gone months too long how did inserting
the question the pronoun games distant
cousin yes all the garlic and holy water
and sunlight weapons are garbage I must
get my samurai sword if I'm to win this
fight these Foot Clan ninjas are
excellent at dodging bullets or else
reincarnated Whistler sucks at aiming or
both I mean what are you gonna do -
Whistler at this point it's gonna make
me worried about his well-being he
literally just came back from the dead
five minutes ago
also Whistler once the assassin takes
his gun just stands there as if they
digitally inserted Chris Christopherson
standing in his trailer in the shot even
though these two vampires are there to
ask for blades help to fight the
creepers they still waste time fighting
him instead of laying down their weapons
and saying don't kill us we're here to
talk I'll be goddamned if you can
explain to me anything that's happening
during this 12 seconds of fighting oh
yeah but God yeah but you broke in and
shut down the security system first
they're offering you a truce they want
to meet with you that's why they sent a
ninja assassins and not you know carrier
pigeons or one of those harmless bike
messenger services still disappointed I
know he's not asking me this question
but yes I am God's a human D as good can
tell that sort of thing from a great
distance even though all the guards are
covered from head to toe blade this is
overlord Elie Thomas quino's aka
overlord stupid name is ski nose
you're human daddy I'm a lawyer ha ha
you know what you call that a good start
oh wait I forgot to actually tell the
joke to this punchline much like this
movie did recruiting blade via a
PowerPoint presentation it takes us in
deeper than we've ever been get a chance
to see how their world really takes you
are half vampire dude you've been
fighting them for years how much of a
mystery can the vampire world really be
at this point vampire movie uses
time-lapse footage of the Sun moving
cliche look if you want to be secretive
about that don't do it in a room some
random recently met chick and just walk
into and see your light Hema Fairlane
and several other names you'll forget in
a few minutes because this movie is
nothing if not forgettable and wry not
oh it's Ron Perlman Ron utter waste of a
badass like Donnie Yen you will attach
to Hunter you started with the prey I
get that blade is a great vampire hunter
and killer and everything but it seemed
really necessary for their cause the
vampires seem to have a huge organized
network of fighters yet for some reason
they can't take out the currently
limited number of creepers without
imploring the help of their worst enemy
I guess if they didn't get him involved
they wouldn't have these beautiful
nuggets of wisdom like this one where he
basically says go to where you expect
your enemy to be Reinhardt licks blood
off his fingers that came from the back
of his own head which is weird for two
reason he enjoys the taste of his own
blood and also he's a vampire that still
has blood for some reason one French
with this should blow your target up
like a balloon
we couldn't into a bullet so he made it
into a glove also the discount queue is
explaining his weapons on the fly on the
job during a fight sniper buddy is
basically useless once they go
underground right the director and set
decorator had an obvious disagreement
over the definition of enough graffiti
this is like the Steve Martin from SNL's
medieval barber sketch Hall of Fame
played franchise challenges matrix
franchise for a record of most Club
scenes in the first 25 minutes of each
movie and a franchise record how are any
of these panels having fun on the dance
floor so packed that sardine cans look
down on it whatever the business somehow
in this crowded dance club both these
assholes were able to zero in on their
intended target without any writhing
sweaty dancers getting in the way like
the first movie this vampire club is
just a death machine tell me at what
point do people stop going to vampire
clubs do you
making ping smell blade over all the
potential human blood another vampire
sense in the air really
here's dining in again being completely
misused again he just FedEx himself a
box of donuts or did he already have a
FedEx box that had a box of donuts
inside regardless of the circumstance
its simplest that damn these are the
most obvious eyesore surveillance
cameras ever deployed in a movie even on
a dance floor this crowded I'm not sure
this obvious vampire could blend in for
even three seconds but here is blending
in and being unnoticed by the hyper
alert security here and attacking
Hellboy that guy's got one of the guns
full of blanks from die hard too
that's the only explanation for how he
doesn't hit this vampire right here I'm
glad we know that after wasting hundreds
of rounds yes this will hurt the vampire
attached to the front of your vehicle
but won't kill him and it should hurt
you the driver as much as it hurts the
vampire holding on to the outside of
this RV they gave this movies vampires
predator mouths and I've already
compared these things to aliens so I
guess it's a raging aliens vs. predator
conflict going on inside these things
what are you doing kill that beast god
damn it see this mother there should be
dead already
sorry also it's kind of amazing how much
this movie vampire gig resembles his
eventual TV gig know constantly escaping
the undead I mean this is basically a
Darrell from The Walking Dead audition
tape here why don't you just travel
everywhere with these UV lights turned
on homeboys girlfriend doesn't check his
body and notice the giant bite mark on
his neck
having the same conversation we had less
than 10 minutes ago blade will now go
fisticuffs with this vampire instead of
drawing a sword and ending the bastard
instantly some way ex machina which I
imagine is how most of Blades battles
end at least the ones that take place
near dawn why didn't you tell me these
things were Mewtwo silver and garlic I
didn't know this movie has what the
common vampire lore long enough I say no
thank you sir two mutated vampires that
are immune to all classic vampire
weapons
no no also did they try to do anything
about the creepers before they call
blade
you'd think this would be something they
discover pretty quickly she requests a
tooth loose be squeezed onto her gloved
finger and it's done but still but could
have been acid so easily
requesting an on glove sample and
sniffing it is potentially lethal except
for this chick here who's probably
Zeus's daughter or some neurotoxin god
damn you figured that out fast and by
sight and smell
Reapers are also filled with caramel the
heart is encased in bone and E is a
stomach vagina you're about one con hair
away from hillbilly heaven that's
several things just the only difference
between us is that I made peace with
what I am a long time ago and also he's
a reared a walker and you're just a
vampire but whatever they say I know
Janet and Chrissy start tearing chunks
out of my stomach
blade shows up yeah luckily considering
you're ultimately a mole for the vampire
dude I mean the plan was to place a mole
through vampire attack and can hope
blade stopped it that's the stupidest
plan ever this is the second or third
obvious Powerpuff Girls shot in this
movie and I'm over here like but
thankfully for this montage all these
assholes were testing out gear and
equipment at the same time and
side-by-side
well when you put it like that no I'm a
lover not a fighter
40% of scuds dialogue was pulled from a
book of cliches why did we decide to
split everyone up again well yeah she
defeated her foe but she also killed
herself here so why did she do this
again they've overwhelmed this asshole
so how much you want to bet 70 year-old
Whistler still somehow escapes the
scenario corpse stomping the truth oh
man important exposition we're not
allowed to hear a vampire and a vampire
movie courageously lets someone they
care about drink their blood in order to
save that person cliche blade is taken
out like a bitch presumably because he
was so distracted by his love for this
discount Trinity chick I could have a
heart attack and die if not surprised
that this guy is a double-crosser I know
he's rambling about combining vampire
DNA but these visuals could easily be a
commercial for vampire Cologne I've been
onto you
sisty turned you why would you let
somebody like that work for you
you let all sorts of bad stuff happen to
set up a double-cross but did nothing to
actually prevent it we're going to
harvest your blood every drop of it well
he's unconscious know who you're talking
to but regardless this is telling the
hero your entire plan before killing the
cliche anyway now I might add a bit the
person in charge of harvesting blades
organs is a lawyer oh do you think God
really favors in the web spider God
favors the are you actually talking
about God doesn't have time for common
spider fly battles he's too busy writing
American legislation but fortunately for
us he doesn't know this location instead
of letting this be a surprise blade
basically warns the lawyer that no Mac
is coming giving them a moment to
prepare on the plus side it creates this
nice segue I know the bullets don't
really matter to know Mac but as far as
I can tell none of these guys hit him
with a single bullet as he ran right
towards them late dole no matter where
this facility was because why he knew
he'd need Nomex help to defeat all the
bad guys he knew he'd be tased and taken
here he knew too much is my point
Vince not only big enough for a human to
crawl through but big enough for
crippled Whistler to crawl through with
tons of extra breathing room no Mac has
apparently taken his sweet time and fed
on all these soldiers you never hear he
has a lot of faith in the few bodyguards
that no man hasn't killed yet thankfully
for blade speedy recovery the bad guys
had a pool of blood in their underground
compounds that healed him yeah I was
worried which is weird because I've seen
blade Trinity also he shot blade into a
pool of blood and it's walking away from
him as though he did a good thing that
ended the movie
I may never have seen Ron Perlman behave
so stupidly a literal pool of literal
blood would not run off like water on
this dude's face he'd be two-thirds
blood red but movie that is all about
blood has no time for actual blood
physics damn you good timing guards have
good timing
blade is only all-powerful because no
group of foes ever attack him more than
one guy at a time legit WWE move in a
supposedly serious action film hey kid
goddamnit
as usual vampire battles come down to
punching so it comes down to no Mack
super vampire of nebulous powers versus
blade super vampire of nebulous powers
great awesome
way too many minutes of a fight scene I
can barely follow or comprehend even
though its outcome a certain blade takes
her up to the roof to die viewing the
sunlight but why not dip her in the
magic blood pool that healed you these
movies have shown us so many
resurrections it's kind of hilarious
they now want us to be sad over a
chick's death
I'll trade with anyone that has a
jacuzzi
I can't see too long
five my colonia that may not wanna
foster forces with me
Papa's got a brand-new bag I get it
you have a lot of gun had tonight what
do we got here the victims penis was
found behind the AC unit ouch
can you say dick sicko
[Music]